hey sally it's obviously very hot
outside but it's not stopping all these
tourists from standing in line
and taking the iconic las vegas sign
picture las vegas is heating up
not only with the many events making a
comeback this weekend but the thousands
of tourists coming in for them during
these record-breaking
triple digit temperatures this is really
hot i mean
i was in the military qatar was hot
this is hot but the heat did not stop
tourists from going on with their plans
and making the most of their time in las
vegas
right now it's really hot but we are
enjoying just the weather
and we spend a really good time with my
friends and
i think this experience is amazing
ventura is staying cool with his mini
fan
right now it's not working because it
doesn't have battery
but yeah the rogers family is visiting
from new york and came prepared for the
heat
fan like this with water and we're just
trying to keep
crawling we're also wetting the top of
our hat
they were amongst the dozens of people
that stood in line to take a picture
with the las vegas sign
they say the extreme heat does not scare
them it's ok
you're on vacation you've got to live
the good life a lot of these folks i
spoke to say they're just going to
continue to find creative ways to stay
cool
and go on with their plans that they
originally had before they knew it was
going to be this hot
reporting from the las vegas strip
victoria saha 8 news now